with your grades and extracurriculars
you have a shot of getting into any
college I can't you can no I mean I
can't leave
Wildflower follows B and her family and
the challenges that they face Dad don't
forget you have a dermatologist
appointment today this wonderful
Charming Brave young woman who was born
to a parent with intellectual disability
please tell me you didn't wear those in
public
I thought they were funny the beauty of
this story is she had to grow up a lot
quicker but underneath she knows that
love is all there is and that's what
matters in life it's about how a family
navigates those Waters with fear and
love the way you sip your teeth the
memory
all that my favorite stories are the
ones that are funny one minute and have
you crying in this because that is what
life is like look at her the part of her
brain that makes her horny is still
working and then I met the director and
that sealed it for me
this is his family's freaking amazing
story and he captured a dynamic I think
he could only capture if you know what
it's like to be in it place is a mess
I'm delighted by the cast and I love
this script so much
and we have an amazing actress playing
the disabled parents why aren't you
dressed I'm getting a snack first and
she herself is on the autistic Spectrum
you cannot take be by yourself
when I was like I want to be an actor
everyone's like oh well you can't do
that you don't know how to
excuse me I have to pretend to be normal
every day
an actual actress with an intellectual
disability you don't get to see that on
screen very often unfortunately
I play her mother and wonderful Jackie
Weaver plays the other other in the
story Loretta I swear to God I told you
that won't work Jean Smart is the
elegant gracious grandma and I'm the old
my son's not gonna go to hell because of
your trollop
[Music]
a very long time worrying about other
people I think it's time to focus on you
for a while this is just such a special
project object and it's so wonderfully
done
it's very heartfelt and so funny you
gotta learn how to dress
I'm 10. it's romantic it's sad and
Incredibly entertaining I'm just so
happy to be part of this story
[Music]
foreign